you were saying something about you're
going to replace johnny knoxville
you said you're coming for his spot
that's what you say i said nothing of
the sort yeah but uh i i did fight
pretty hard um when the contract
negotiations were how much did you want
how much did you want i i didn't um i
didn't really get [ __ ] no how much did
you want though how much did i want
five million
was it a number uh like a dollar amount
or a percentage amount it was uh
i'm i'm trying to remember definitely i
wanted more points
okay you want to back up yeah i
definitely want it back and that's
always been kind of a business
look at his dad he knows what he's doing
yeah yeah yeah and um and you know the
reality is you say you're the pepsi of
japan
i don't need a coke is that what's going
on and you guys are like vying for the
top spot i'm more of the lenin
[Applause]
take that johnny
and then there is no war
sure you know there there is no work
yeah but um
the uh the the
the whole attention [ __ ] in me the look
at me and and knoxville has always been
like such a like a big brother you know
and and the jackass director jeff
tremaine's always been like this
demented father figure you know and like
spike jones who's also one of the
he's just been this like god-like figure
you know and like
like these guys their opinion you know
you spend your whole life trying to get
your dad to approve of you and you know
like you always want like the
the privilege
you know that that's what it's like
that's what it's like yeah so so going
into that everything that i was fighting
for i mean really what i wanted was just
for them to acknowledge like hey you
know
stevo for the last 10 years you [ __ ]
worked you've been killing it and i
wanted just that acknowledgement yeah
and did they give you that no
damn you didn't get the points or the
love [ __ ] dude
i didn't get [ __ ] but um in hindsight
it was i mean and
up to that point
in in my career with jackass i had never
once
even
countered an offer it was always on
every season of the tv show every one of
the movies it was always merely an
exercise in me finding out what they
were willing to give me and accepting it
yeah yeah yeah and that that had eaten
at me and i just thought man
i never stood up for myself i never
fought for more and i wanted to do it
differently with this last movie and in
doing so
i've now had that experience
i've scratched that itch it didn't get
me anywhere he bled you know i'm glad
that i don't have to spend the rest of
my life wondering what it would have
been like to fight for myself and now i
know and it's not worth it you're saying
it's it's really not and
in this in in in the case of jackass i'm
not saying it's not worth a fight for
yourself johnny like a ruthless
businessman i mean the collective of
dickhouse productions which is what it
is yeah um
they're i mean i
yeah they're they're uh
they're really intense businessman but
they're also absolute geniuses you know
i mean it's unbelievable
i had so much fun watching it i think
the first time i even started watching
like this genre was when the cky2k tape
came out and i remember me and my
friends like for a summer trying to like
tie a leash on a bee after we froze it
oh my god
they did that yeah they did all these
amazing pranks it was so funny
and uh and then obviously jackass came
on and then it was just so entertaining
you just you could not look away and you
were this [ __ ] superstar on it and um
and johnny's really stolen your look
he's starting to speak like you he got
teeth even
he's coming for you bro he's coming for
your [ __ ] dude i don't know that
knoxville's
teeth aren't real
if they're not he got him a long [ __ ]
time ago because i don't think they've
changed have they no i'm just
they they have not um
i mean dude like i can't take anything
away from knoxville or dickhouse and i'm
glad that i tried to fight for myself
i'm happy that i had the experience but
in hindsight and if there are any uh
future
jackass projects i'm never going to
bother with that again because the
reality is
i have worked hard enough to set up all
these other different revenue streams
so the movie comes out and it's an
engine driving all of my other revenue
streams so i might have the same exact
contract as any number of the other guys
on jackass but i get more out of it
because i've got other stuff set up yeah
damn that was a shot yo
all of you guys heard that what was that
yo i got other stuff set up so i might
get more
the other guys
but you're right
a lot of dudes i don't want to get in
trouble on another podcast
everything's fine
[Laughter]
yeah i mean that's the thing that johnny
constantly does i feel like
i feel like if you just finally just
quit that [ __ ] and just let you be great
the great guy that you are then
everything will be fine but yeah let's
let's go check out his website you want
to see it okay johnny
knoxville.com okay all right it sounds
like it would be johnny knoxville's
website yeah i'm over 18. let's check it
out oh you have to be 18 and enter
[Music]
okay
well those are those are penises in
there coming on johnny knoxville's hair
changing the color of it to gray it's
grey hair yeah i think that wow and now
it's
a guy with balls like a pit bull and a
cavernous [ __ ]
well now we're inside the [ __ ] for
everybody who's not staying at home
wow okay and it seems like all you can
buy on johnny knoxville's website is
stevo merch
is this an elaborate prank
that we're watching right now um
it's a high level prank war that we did
engage in fairly recently okay
yeah no no and when we
that we being my team yeah this devo
team when we looked up johnny
knoxville.com
we somehow found it to be available for
purchase
and i bought it and
i'm the proud owner of johnnydoxel.com
and i would love to encourage everyone
to go and see this incredible thing that
i've built
you should have t-shirts that are just
johnnyknoxville.com as your merch yeah
yeah i went into johnny knoxville's
butthole and all i got was this
[Applause]
you